hey it's working all right so yeah so I
think maybe some of you have seen this
talk before I give it two weeks ago at
the fine-grained complexity seminar here
at Simons and yeah so I'm sorry if
you're hearing it again but you know
you're here too for the fine-grained
complexity and I think this is one of
the most fine-grained results so hope
you like it second time so one of the
results that are going to be tell you
about is this potluck shape is a lower
bound made and in this is what I'm going
to show you is that you can take some
result some shaving locks result that
looks like a very algorithms resort like
a very slow the paper and then you know
we show that this already implies a very
ccc result very complexity result some
class does not have some kind of boolean
formulas so but before we get there let
me tell you the story so the main
problem that I'll be talking about for
most of the talk is the LCS so the
longest common subsequence very very
basic and simple you have two strings
two sequences of length n and you ask
what is the longest sequence that
appears on both of them as a subsequence
in this example this is subsequence
there appears in both and you can think
of it as some kind of matching problem
trying to find the maximum matching
between the two strings ok so in
undergrad you've all seen an N squared
time algorithm it's known how to shave a
log squared factor but this is this is
the best known and you know very very
you know important question is can you
do better
if you don't like LCS you can think
about edit distance as well in the stock
so it's the the famous problem you have
two sequences and you ask what is the
minimum number of insertions deletions
substitutions that you need in order to
transform one into the other again it's
pretty it's pretty basic as an easy
definition but it also has a lot of
applications a very important problem
practice and again the best algorithm is
a sin squared over log squared and if
you generalize at a distance a bit
further you can get some problems that
are very very important for biology for
example like this local line my problem
you're given two DNA sequences and you
want to find out the two kind of parts
that are most similar to each other
under some similarity that is defined
with some scoring matrix and people want
to solve this problem on huge sequences
and it's like a few billions and in this
case this N squared over log squared is
just too slow and you know as a proof
that this is too slow and that it's very
important there's this paper from the
90s that you know shows a linear time
algorithm for this problem that is not
it's a heuristic doesn't can prove that
it works in this paper has got more than
50,000 citations so it's a very
important problem yeah so and you know
we really want to know if these problems
can be solved faster and recently we
showed that with Virginia and Oren we
showed that it release of quadratic
algorithm you know it refutes strong
exponential time I posters I'll tell you
about later but this was for the kind of
the harder version of the problem and
then in a really great result our tours
and Pyotr showed that the same lower
bound holds even for edit distance this
is a great theory paper but it also had
you know it made it to the news it's a
wonderful result yeah and so and
follow-up works extended this lower
bound for a distance also to LCS longest
common subsequence problem a nice work
by carl and marvin kind of
gives a general framework for getting
these strong eth lower bounds it says
that any problem that asks you to
compute some similarity measure over two
sequences and when the similarity
measure has some kind of property it
admits alignment gadgets then you're
going to get this quadratic lower bound
on there are strong eth and some
examples that they show in their
framework is a distance in LCS even on
binary sequences so the problem is
tailored even when the alphabet is
binary another example is this dynamic
time warping distance from like speech
recognition okay and of course this
results are a part of this long line of
work on strong eth robot that has
there's a long list of such lower
balance from all over computer science
and this is a part of the bigger picture
of like the conditional lower bounds in
p that this workshop is about and what
the work that i'm telling you about what
we do is we look at this class and we
find a subclass of it there is much
harder than the rest yeah so so let's
let's go back to the stronger th and
look at it this conjecture that's giving
us all these lower bounds it's about k
sath so you are given a que CNF formula
and you're asked whether it's
satisfiable so for any fixed k you can
do better than 2 to the n you can do 1.9
to the end for any small enough k but as
k grows this this becomes 2 to the N and
strongly th essentially says that
there's no epsilon such as for all K you
can solve a case at in 2 minus epsilon
to the N you can think of it as just
saying that CNF SAT so just you know
you're given a CNF you don't restrict
the width of the clause it's going to be
solved in 2 minus epsilon to the N okay
so it's it's you know it's a plausible
assumption i find it plausible because
exit is like one of the most famous
problem was 30 problems in computer
science so you know if there were faster
algorithms you know we would expect
found them but there aren't that many
reasons to believe it so if it's false
then you know so it's not that it like
it's true for certain kinds of
algorithms and so on but there's no very
surprising consequences of it being
false so in this work we kind of look at
this conjecture and we look at the CNF
part and we say that it's it's kind of
the weakness of strong eth and let me
tell you why so a general sad problem it
looks like this you're given some
function sum function be that take some
n bits and outputs one bit and set asks
you whether this function is satisfiable
is there some input that makes it up put
one and if you just you know treat this
function as a black box you don't try to
analyze or anything then of course you
need the kind of 2 to the N queries for
this so you're going to need to to the
end time but of course the clever
algorithm is going to try to analyze the
function that it's given to them with
some representation and and the hardness
of set depends on how alpha skating this
representation is so for example if the
function is giving in a dnf form or of
ends then you know it's super easy to
solve set on these things you know just
check whether you know it's super
trivial you can do it in linear time
on the other hand if the function is
represented with a complex you know code
of some during machine or some complex
thing that is you know trying to
obfuscate the kind of functionality of
the function then you know we have no
idea how to figure out whether it's
satisfiable and other examples if you're
just giving some complex circuit you
know with current kind of ideas that we
have in computer science we don't know
how to analyze circuits and understand
whether there are satisfiable and so so
there's this hierarchy of a kind of sad
problems at the bottom we have these dnf
that are very easy to you know figure
out their satisfiable not and we have
complex things like not thermy securing
machines that we don't know how to
analyze and in the middle of course
there's there's many things example if
you look at poly log dev circuits the
class NC then these things are capable
of computing many many kind of complex
functions like one-way functions and all
sorts of things from cryptography that
you know they try to obfuscate their
behavior and and what so what's strong
eth they're kind of the standard strong
eth says is that even on this like
hierarchy even something that's very low
like a CNF is it's hard to solve SAT for
even when you're given a CNF you cannot
do 2 minus epsilon to the N and because
of the specification lemma you can even
assume that the CNF has linear size so
even when I give you a linear size CNF
you cannot analyze it and so upset and
notice that when you go a little bit
lower so three CNF for example it's
known how to do it in 1.4 to the end so
so this is kind of the lowest place
where you can put the line and the
higher up you go you can define the
corresponding set and then it becomes
more and more plausible and the main
question that we ask in this work is can
we prove lower bounds and they're this
more complex strong eth so for more calm
class of circuits see or function see
can we show you know base kind of the
hardness and P framework on the cset
that would be give us a better kind of
foundation for for our lower bounds and
this this kind of wasn't obvious at all
because all these strong eth lower
bounds they really abuse discipline
citty of CNF if you've seen them you you
know what I'm talking about okay and so
this is our main result we go very high
up in the hierarchy we show that you can
reduce that on very complex things like
non-deterministic branching programs to
very fundamental problems like LCS at a
distance and some others so now we can
base lower bounds under this much more
plausible branching programs set so let
me tell you what Bengie programs are in
case you haven't seen them before so a
branching program is just a graph it's a
layer graph it has some width so each
layer has w nodes think of W as three or
five it has T layers this is the length
of the program and you think of T as
being some polynomial and it's a
computational model so you give it some
input and it tells you it either accepts
or rejects and the way it does it is by
looking at the graph so each edge in
this graph is labeled by some kind of
constraint each each edge says x i
equals 0 or X i equals 1 for some X I
and once you get an input it kind of
restricts the edges that are satisfied
by this input and then the question just
becomes whether there is a path from s
to T from the start node to the except
note of the program you can also think
of non deterministic branching programs
the difference between the two is that
in the deterministic case each node has
two outgoing edges one labeled with x i
equals 0 1 with one but in the
non-deterministic case you can have
multiple edges label
I like x3 equals one can have more than
one place to go to and so when you
restrict the the input when you're
giving some input you look at the
restricted program in the deterministic
case it's just the degrees are all one
but in general it can be like you know
it's rich restricts some sub graph and
it's a rich ability problem can sh t in
this sub graph and so the branching
programs set is your given some
branching program on n variables also
notice that the each variable is going
to appear many times in this program the
length is like polynomial into the 10
but there's only n variable so each
variable appears many times so I give
you some branching program on n
variables say polynomial lengths
constant width and I ask you if it's
satisfiable you know so this is the
wrench program set a naive algorithm
just tries all inputs and just you know
checks which ability or whatever and it
runs in like 2 to the N time essentially
and the branching program says is that
you cannot solve this in 1.99 to the N
so here's here's our main result so it's
it's a reduction we show that you can
take set on anther mystic branching
programs on n variables with W and
length T and you can reduce it either to
edit distance on binary sequences or LCS
on binary sequences where the length of
these sequences is 2 to the N over 2
which is the big term times some
dependence on the length and the width
and this notice that in the kind of
standard case where the length is
polynomial and the width is constant
this is a polynomial factor so it's it's
much smaller than this 2 to the N over 2
and so from this reduction we get the
corollary that if LCS can be solved in
truly sub quadratic time then you can
solve certain branching programs that
are very huge like you know might have
with five but the length can be due to a
little event even for such huge things
you can
figure out set and 2 minus Delta to the
end time so why am I telling you about
these branching programs well this this
models of computation are very
expressive so you can take any kind of
Turing machine that uses just like log W
space and and runs in times T and just
you know look we can reduce this to a
branching program of with W and length T
so it can you know it could represent
doubted space computations very well
there's also the famous Barrington's
theorem that says that any circuit of
depth D can be there's an equivalent
branching program on the same input that
that has with five and four to the
length so for this implies that if you
have nc1 circuits locked up circuits
then they can be just translated into
polynomial lengths branching programs
even if you had NC circuits poly log
depth circuits then they still have
branch programs of pseudo polynomial
size which will still be captured by our
our theorem and so because of this
express ability of the branching
programs we get these corollaries so if
you solve at a distance or LCS intrusive
quadratic time you solve sat on huge
things faster so one thing is any
circuit of little o of n depth is much
bigger than the class NC you can even
solve sat on non-deterministic turing
machines as long as they use little of
square root n space and even on
arbitrary boolean formulas of two to the
low event size so yeah so it's going to
be very hard so of LCS faster that's it
that's what I'm saying and yeah I think
it's you know it's evident that these
consequences are big just to give you
more kind of to convince you let me tell
you about what they would imply what
these consequences would imply so for
that I'm going to tell you about the
circuit lower bounds barrier what is
this thing so so this is kind of an
argument not not that not that you know
that some consequence is going to be
very surprising or like it will imply
something that we think is false it's
just
say that the consequence that you get
from something from some algorithm say
it's going to be it's believed to be
very hard to show and so getting such
algorithm is going to require you to you
know to invent like a lot of new
techniques so you know to get this
connection to Circuit lower bounds we're
going to use this line of work of Ryan
which basically says that from faster
set algorithms you can get circuit lower
bounds and what his work shows is that
if you solve sat on circuits from some
Class C and 2 to the N over some
polynomial in n like into the 10 so you
improve exhaustive search then you get
some that some complexity class is not
in some circuit class and using this
connection he has this famous result
that the class NX was not in an acc 0
okay so it was not before that's that
there was some circuit lower bounds
barrier from strong bth so it's known
that refuting strong eth implies some
new lower bond because you can take
their some circuits this series parallel
circuits that can translate well into c
NFS and then from faster CNF you can get
some you know new circuit lower bounds
but you know just to kind of explain
what I how I am thinking of these things
without like complexity language so this
is what this this means so there's this
line where complex theory is today and
there's you know it goes on to where we
would like to be where the things we
really want to show and this consequence
that you get from strong GTH being false
is really a tiny tiny improvement
whereas what we get you know from the
new reduction is that a faster LCS and
edit distance implies the circuit lower
bound that seem very very far in the
future they are very very strong like
you know this one was like linear size
formulas and here we have due to little
oven
yeah so this kind of shows is you know
if you want to be a circuit lower bounds
millionaire you know try to solve LCS
faster that's one way to do it okay so
this was our first result we basically
took these strong eth rubber bands and
we say you don't need to assume struggle
th you can assume something much more
believable the second second result that
I'm going to tell you about that you get
from this work is is that the even
shaving glogs is going to be hard
there's a barrier for that all right so
now let's look at my place of quadratic
algorithms so as I told you the current
based algorithm for these problems is
this log squared improvement and it's
been a long standing open question to
improve this log squared so get anything
better than that and you know when when
you have such an important problem like
at the distance this is a very important
question like we really want to know the
exact complexity of these problems and
recent techniques showed the kind of
similar you know shaving block
breakthroughs for other very fundamental
problems like 43 someone real numbers
and and this is a and this work by Ryan
for all pair shortest paths and this
technique so the technique that he
introduced so it shaves log to the
little o of 1 of n so it shaves log to
the sea for all constancy it's kind of a
clean shape and using the same technique
their results that get clean shapes for
other problems that look kind of pretty
similar to LCS and edit distance for
example the longest common substring of
two sequences so a substring is a
contiguous subsequent we got some some
big girl is saving there so this
naturally led to the question that's
been stayed in many of these papers as
whether you can do edit distance or LCS
with this technique and this you know
shave logs for them
and from the previous work from the
stronger th lower bounds the we could
not say anything about this because even
if you get these results you wouldn't
get a new algorithm for CNF SAT I mean
you would get some algorithm but it
would be slower than the currently known
algorithms but what from our reduction
because we start from circuit from
circuits not see NFS then these savings
are going to imply new SAT algorithms
and so here's an example such an
algorithm so take NC one's side so sat
on lock depth circuits barons theorem
just gives you a branching programs of
polynomial length and width 5 and from
our reduction you get instances of LCS
on to the N over 2 times poly and
sequences and then if you do this clean
shave for LCS this implies 2 to the N
over arbitrary large polynomial for NC
one set and from Ryan's work this
implies that some class is not in an NC
1 so you get this circuit lower bound
that would be a very big breakthrough so
yeah so it's going to be hard to get
this improvement but now let's be even
more fine-grained and see you know how
many locks can be shaped that that once
said that you're not going to shave all
Polliwogs so here let's just be a less
kind of ambitious let's just look at the
lower bounds for specific polynomials so
let's say we want to show that this
class doesn't have formulas of size n to
the 5 this is not known it's not known
how to show these things with current
techniques so then we look at set on
formulas of size n to the 5 and with
some kind of complexity translations we
get some branching programs of some size
and from our reduction we get sequences
of to the N over 2 times n to the 800
this is a kind of some some constant
that depends on the five it's a fixed
number and then we show that if you
shave this locked 804 LCS then you get
fast enough set to to imply the lower
bound
okay so i'm gonna i'm going to tell you
the proof of a reduction in next to fly
a few slides but so when i get this talk
two weeks ago you know it was so clear
that the people after the talk like you
understood it so well that they told me
how to improve it and they observed that
we don't even need to go through
branching programs we can just reduce
formula set directly from our gadgets to
to LCS and when you do that you get kind
of a tighter connection instead of eight
hundred you can go down to 80 and so
we're going we're getting down with
these logs and of course we would really
like to get tight bounds we would like
to kind of give reasons for why even
another you know log log is hard yeah
but i think we're getting there i'll say
a bit more about this in the end and so
one kind of cool thing that this says
that when undergrads you know we're
giving them LCS in order you know basic
classes and you know they think whether
they can solve it faster and so on what
they're really trying to do is that
they're trying to prove new circuit
lower bounds all right so the rest of
the talk is gonna i'm going to tell you
about the reduction i'm going to show
you how this works how you can take
branching programs and and simulate them
with else yet so LCS can you know encode
an algorithm for for branching programs
that but let me just say that so yeah
i'm going to do this one reduction to
LCS gonna i'm going to use a kind of
large alphabet and so on but in the
paper we show that any problem for which
the general framework of Carolyn Marvin
that shows strong eth lower bounds the
stronger th can be replaced with the
branch program strong eth and so you can
get the same lower bound for edit
distance LCS on binary sequences for
example but we all show lower bounds for
things that are not that framework like
computing the LCS of k sequences it's an
entity k problem and we show that
improving improvement over that are also
hard but so we don't know how to replace
all of the strong GTH lower bounds with
with this new
some very interesting open question are
about say the diameter of Sparta graph
the rich ability in dynamic graphs and
subsidize a morphism these are problems
that we do have strong eth trailer burns
but we don't know how to get this harder
hot hardness so you know when i show you
the you're familiar with these strong
eth lower bands it'll be cool to think
about how wide it breaks for these
problems and whether you can try to do
it in some other way okay so here's the
outline for for the reduction so and i'm
gonna restrict myself to with five and
the polynomial length and so we're going
to start from branchy program set the
first step is going to read you it's
going to be an easy step to some some
kind of pair problem that it's kind of
like the orthogonal pairs problem when
when we work with strong eth and then
we're going to reduce this to some LCS
spare problem and then to LCS so what I
mean let me just go ahead and start
doing this steps so so this is our first
step so we take tech branching programs
that say we're given some branching
program and we're trying to figure out
if there's some input that makes it you
know mix s able to reach t and so our
first step is just going to be to split
the inputs into two sets so look at all
bit vectors of length n over 2 and put
put them here and then put them there
call these a call them be what I just
reformulated the side problem to this
problem where I ask you to find one bit
vector from here and one bit vector from
here that together when you put them
together as a satisfying assignment they
satisfy the branching program okay so
when you pick one from here it you said
half of the variables so when you set up
the variables you get some edges the you
restrict some of the edges in the
branching programs that you can use and
then picking the other half restrict
some other edges and then the question
is you know can you find a pair that
makes it so that you you can
each your your target so this you know
it's not gonna be useful for the rest of
the proof but it's a cool way to think
about this problem that we're reducing
from is that it's kind of a graph
problem now you have some underlying
graph and say polynomial number of nodes
and then you're given two lists of sub
graphs long list like 2 to the N over 2
sub graphs each one is you know telling
you some edges and then you're trying to
find a pair such that when you put the
edges together you get a path from s to
T this might be in so for future
reductions so back to to our proof so
after you kind of split the variables
into two sets and you're trying to find
a pair that satisfies the branch program
now we start talking about LCS so we're
going to do is we're going to take each
bit vector and we're going to transform
it into some sequence over some alphabet
we're going to do this for each one you
know each one the first place in the
second list and then we're going to look
for a pair of sequences such that the
LCS of this pair is large this is what I
call the LCS pair problem we are given
to list of sequences they're pretty
short they're going to be like
polynomial length whereas the number is
exponential and you're trying to find a
pair that has large LCS and then we're
going to take this LCS pair problem and
we're going to reduce it to 12 yes bye
so in LCS you only have two sequences
not like not lists and this step is just
going to be from previous work I'm not
gonna tell you about it if you haven't
seen this before a trophy looks like
this you take this the first list list
of sequences you just put them in one
sequence with some padding between some
cleverly chosen padding then you take
the second list and you put them in some
other sequence and then you argue that
if a good pair existed then the total
LCS of these two sequences is going to
be large okay so back to the outline so
this is what i was saying so you start
from branch programs that you are used
to the pair problem this is just a
reformulation it's not nothing's going
on there's the green arrow it's very
easy
then we are going to our main kind of
thing is to tell you how to get go from
these bit vectors to these sequences
that such that like the LCS is checking
satisfiability and then then once we are
this LCS pair we just use previous work
and then we go to LCS and let me just
compare this with the strongest eh lower
bounds so here the difference is
essentially in this arrow and here this
was conceptually it's very easy I mean
it was hard to prove because you had to
do all these gadgets but what was really
going on here is because you had some
two bit vectors and you were asking you
know we're trying to find two vectors
such as in every coordinate one of them
is zero this was this question and then
reducing it to LCS was conceptually very
easy you just take each coordinate and
you know turns in some sequence and such
that to kind of sequences tell you if
there's one of them is zero then you
combine them you know it was simple but
here it's it's it's not because you know
the the tube the sequences are trying to
check you know reach ability and some
rain check program and so on ok so but
so this is how we're going to do it
so alright so now fixed and branching
program you know this is the input to
the reduction it's some branching
program fix it and then and now fix a
pair of bit strings a and B for this bit
string where and for this a and B we're
going to will tell you how to produce
the two gadgets and i'm going to show
you that these gadgets are going to work
well so we really want is that the
healthiest of these two gadgets is large
when there's a path from s to t when you
restrict your your inputs according to a
and B and today's we're going to do a
more general construction of reach
ability gadgets so for any pair of nodes
in the branching programs U and V we're
going to construct some gadget spare I'm
tried by U and V and the the bit bit
string a and similarly for be such that
we can prove some properties of these
gadgets first property is the kind of
important one the LCS of this these two
sequence is going to be large larger
sums done some parameter that depends on
on k so k is the so the length in the US
at some layer vis some layer and the
distance is due to the k so the LCS will
be large when there's a path and then
the length of these gadgets is not going
to be too bad it's going to be
exponential in k and we're going to
construct this in linear time and and
what we have this we're done because
then we just you know construct these
gadgets for where u and v are just s and
T and then k is log the length of the
branching program and this exponential
in the log is it's going to become
polynomial in the length so how do we
construct these gadgets
yes yes yeah in general there's some
dependence on the with so it's some with
the constant times okay
okay so here's the main idea so we have
some node you and some node V we want to
know if there's a path from u to V we're
just going to do this recursively we're
going to assume we know whether there's
weather for we're going to look at the
middle layer between them look at the
notes there and just say that you know
this kind of logical quality so there's
a path from u to V if and only if one of
these things happen either there's a
path from u to w1 and from w 1 to V or
you know or through w or w 3 this is
kind of what savages theorem does and so
the kind of demand think that we do is
that we notice that each one of these
checks we're going to be able to
constructive recursively so we're going
to assume we have for all K less than
you know for smaller k we did construct
some gadgets that do what we want they
do tell us reach ability and then we're
going to combine this level K minus 1
gadgets with this kind of logical
relationship into our new gadgets okay
so the point is that this constraint is
going to happen it's going to be true if
the LCS is large all right and and and
here's here what it looks like it's a
very simple construction so I'm telling
you how to construct the gadgets of
leveled k and i'm assuming i have a
level k minus 1 gadgets so take the the
two level k minus 1 gadgets that
correspond to w1 and then just put them
next to each other in the first sequence
and then the second sequence you do the
same and then you put some you kind of
package them together with some padding
this functions as an end so these
paddings you put are very expensive you
always want to match them and then once
you match them you have to match this to
that in this to that and the score of
the matching of these two parts is
really the sum of this matching and that
matching and this one was kind of large
if there was a path through
from you to w1 this one was large if
there's a path from w 1 to V and so the
total score will be good of these two
parts if if there's a pass through w one
this was our implementation of an ant
gadget and then so okay we take we take
the this one was for w1 we take the same
one for w2 and w3 you put them next to
each other and now we want to implement
on or so we want to let the LCS choose
one of them at least one of them so the
past will go through it and we're going
to do this by adding some more padding
so before I explain how this or gadget
padding works let me just say that you
know once we have this we're done
because so these paddings that we're
putting here so this cube its length is
going to be X may be 10 times the total
length of the level K minus one gadget
and then the more expensive ones like
the P and and the are there going to be
you know ten times doesn't enzymes that
but in total the total length of this
whole thing is maybe 10 to the four
times the length of the lower level one
and so you know the higher you go in the
in the levels you get some exponential I
think the total length is going to be
exponential in K this is what we wanted
ok but but let me let me explain why it
works ok so r is the most expensive
letter if you don't match our you lose
it's not your LCS not optimal and there
are only two hours in the first sequence
I'm talking about the case where we have
three the width is 3 but the same
arguments work for larger width so you
have now you have these two hours must
be matched there are more hours here so
you can you have a choice of where to
match them you can either match them to
the right or match one right one left or
both to the left but notice that when
you do these decisions so if you imagine
to the left then these two parts can no
longer be matched do anything meaningful
so this kind of choice said that you
you're really choosing this one
okay so let's assume you did that then
the second most important letter is is
this p and now so there's two only two
piece here then you want to match both
of them and so there's enough piece here
and you just do it and then these two
are not relevant anymore and you're left
with this and that and so then these two
parts start interacting and they
interact in this end kind of way you
match the cues and then you get these
two matchings so the point is all these
kind of pqr matches they have a fixed
contribution they don't depend on the
lower level gadgets but then the orange
arrows they do depend on whether the
there were there was a path and the kind
of the things you records too and so the
total the total LCS of this thing is
going to be large if and only if you
could do this you could find some w to
go through all right and okay so we do
this kind of recursive construction
until we reach the base case and in this
case the K is zero and the two nodes are
on adjacent layers and then we look at U
and V and there's some edge between them
or there's not an edge between them and
then we want to define these gadgets and
now we start looking at the inputs up
until now we didn't look at the a and B
in the bit strings okay
okay all right so now look at this this
edge from u to V and it's it's labeled
by some variable X I this this X I
either belongs 2a or 2b so a is
assigning some half of the variables be
designing some other half of the
variables alright belongs to one of them
say say it belongs to a and then we say
that a is responsible for this variable
and it's responsible for this edge and
so we define aids gadget this way so it
checks whether it's bits are consistent
with the edge so it looks at X I it
checks what it's a boolean value it's
giving it and then if it's consistent
with the edge so if it's giving at zero
and the edge has 0 then it puts this
letter V otherwise it's not consistent
it doesn't agree with this edge
something went wrong in the LCS is
trying to cheat us into taking a path
that doesn't really exist and then we
put some dollar sign and then the other
sequence in be so we basically do the
same except this dollar sign ever
appears so if we put a dollar sign here
then we're not going to be able to match
and the only way we're going to get a
match if both of them put a V and they
put V is only when they're both
consistent and and so if if B was not
responsible for the edge if the very it
doesn't know what this assignment X is
it just puts a V anyway so you only
don't put a V when you don't disagree
with the edge
alright so and this is this is the whole
construction now let me just kind of
give you a pictorial representation of
what's going on in the LCS so say this
is the some level k gadget that
corresponds some U and V and we had this
three parts each corresponding to the
three nodes in the middle and now which
the ELSA is trying to find some path and
say it first chooses to take the first
node in the middle layer so it's going
to match this part in that part and this
part are not going to be irrelevant and
then the LCS is is going to pick some
node in the here say it picks the second
one so the second one here starts
contributing whereas the others don't
don't participate anymore whereas here
in this part maybe you chose the third
one so you go in with this and so on
okay so that's the end of my proof we
just conclude with some kind of recent
progress so as I said if you if you go
do the same with the same gadgets if you
start from formulas you can take sat on
some kind of formulas of size s and get
sequences of sight to the N over 2 times
as to the 80 and buy some kind of
formulas I mean you can not only look at
the end or formulas but you can also
think of other gates and we are hoping
to get 2 to the N over 2 times s and I
think we might be able to get an S
squared and so like you know say say you
did get to the N over 2 times s then you
can show that shaving lock to the C
factor implies this runtime for for
formula set and then you know these
connections might show that shaving
another log for for OCS will imply some
new formula set algorithms but this is
this we're still developing that and
trying to figure out what kind of
statements we can say okay so so again
what we showed is that in this strong
eth class there's a harder subclass you
know you can base it on a better
conjecture and
even has implications the circuit lower
bounds one interesting question is to
see if these other classes the threesome
class or the a PSP class maybe they also
have harder subclasses in them you'll be
interesting to find them and of course
the other interesting question is to get
some these better lower bands for other
problems in the strongly th class
there's time for a question or have you
have you found many problems that are
more than just set hard related to like
circuits app like there's some larger
class of circuits at work than just CNF
where it's work for those besides of
this problem are there any other problem
yeah currently the list is yeah LCS a
distance some other similarity measures
over sequences yeah we don't have yeah
you don't have like graph problems or
other things like that yet but
answering this question their their work
there are problems that are harder than
seeing upset like Max at where there
were problems in polynomial time under
the assumption that those problems
require as connection all right yes yes
though already was known to be hard
under a weaker assumption that's wrong
ETA yeah yes for some lower bounds yes
you can replace CNF SAT with like max
max said yes yeah so I mean there could
actually be a hierarchy you know not
everything can be either CNF SAT or this
Benji program said there could be things
in between yeah
you